[Music]
welcome back everybody before jurors and
derrick shovens trial heard
closing arguments the judge read
instructions to them
about the law long crimes anjanet levy's
here live in minneapolis with what the
joe
the judge told the jurors angenette
yeah jesse jury instructions really lay
out for
the jurors what they are to consider
when evaluating the three charges in
this case
and they are very tedious and at times
confusing
the defendant does not have to prove his
innocence judge peter cahill drafted the
jury instructions with input from the
prosecution and the defense
the instructions are a map for the
jurors
the fact that other causes contribute to
the to the death does not relieve the
defendant of criminal liability
the medical examiner testified that
george floyd's death was a homicide
caused by being restrained by police but
that floyd had heart disease
and fentanyl and methamphetamine in his
system
under the jury instructions chauvin
could still be guilty despite those
facts
chauvin faces three charges
second-degree murder is the most serious
it's an unintentional murder that
happened as a result of a third degree
assault
intent is an element of the assault it
is not necessary that the defendant have
this
intent in advance the necessary intent
can develop
during the commission of the act chauvin
also faces a third degree murder charge
which includes acting with reckless
disregard for life
and conscious indifference a person
causing the death of another
by perpetrating an act eminently
dangerous to others
and evincing a depraved mind without
regard for human life
but without intent to cause the death of
any person second-degree manslaughter is
the lowest level charge
meaning the death was the result of
negligence and the person accused took
actions that had the chance of causing
the death
long crime legal analyst gene rossi
discusses the importance of the
instructions
whatever those instructions are you want
it very
narrow so that when the prosecution
tries to make their closing in rebuttal
they have a very uh thin lane
and and you don't want them to have any
broad brush uh
arguments that they can make now the
jury instructions also include language
about being aided and abetted by
others in the commission of these crimes
that was added since there were three
other officers involved in this incident
jesse terry if the judge explains the
law
then why does the prosecution explain it
again to the jury
question and i'm sure the jury is
thinking the same thing the reason is
because the prosecution has to tie in
the law
to the facts so for instance this
second-degree unintentional murder while
committing an assault
the judge defined what an assault is he
said there is
bodily injury what steve schlesher did
was he explained
bodily injury includes for instance loss
of consciousness and he actually
showed a picture of george floyd when he
was losing consciousness
and when he had the scrapes so he made
that connection between
the assault and what actually happened
and i think he did a great job
now anjanette it's my understanding that
the judge included an instruction to the
jury about
george floyd's drug use am i right
yeah that's correct jesse and he
discussed that this morning
in the morning during the morning
session of the opening statements before
the the opening statements even began
and he said that the drug use
they are not to consider that when
assessing george floyd's character that
is not what this
is about and why it was presented in
court this is about looking at
the condition of george floyd during the
arrest before the arrest
and about what may have caused his death
in the jury's mind so that is why
there's to look at the drug use in this
case
look jury instructions so important they
are a guide map a road map
for this jury the question of course is
do they actually
follow it in the deliberations that's
something we will not know but you
hopefully
think that they will at the end of the
day the jury are human beings and it's
difficult to know what is guiding them
all right coming up on long crime daily
a deeper dive into closing arguments by
the state and defense
in the derrick chauvin trial plus the
former house of a defense defense
witness
targeted the message vandals left after
the break